This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 1984 was a banner year for sci-fi and fantasy. Iconic villains like Freddy Krueger and The Terminator hit the big screen for the first time. William Gibson's Neuromancer turbocharged the cyberpunk genre. Plus franchises like the Transformers and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles burst onto the scene and quickly took up residence on TV, in comic books, and on toy store shelves.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1984年是科幻和奇幻作品的鼎盛之年。弗莱迪·克鲁格和终结者等标志性反派首次登上大银幕。威廉·吉布森的《神经漫游者》为赛博朋克流派注入了强心剂。此外，像《变形金刚》和《忍者神龟》这样的系列作品横空出世，迅速占领了电视、漫画书和玩具店的货架。
Our friend Eric Molinski noticed this cambering explosion of creativity that happened 40 years ago and produced a fantastic series of episodes about it for his podcast Imaginary Worlds. This episode is about the aforementioned Transformers and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, two cultural forces that came about just at the time in 1984 when business people fully recognized that the toys and the media that accompanied them were influencing each other in a constant back and forth conversation, whether the creative people working on them liked it or not. You're listening to Imaginary Worlds, a show about how we create them and why we suspend our disbelief. I'm Eric Mollinsky. I have often talked about how much I love action figures.
我们的朋友埃里克·莫林斯基注意到了40年前发生的这场创意大爆发，并为他的播客《虚构世界》制作了一系列精彩的剧集。本集讲述的是前面提到的《变形金刚》和《忍者神龟》，这两股文化力量出现在1984年，当时商人们完全意识到，玩具和随之而来的媒体内容正在进行持续的互动，无论创作者是否乐意。你正在收听的是《虚构世界》，一档关于我们如何创造虚构世界以及为何要暂停怀疑的节目。我是埃里克·莫林斯基。我经常谈论我有多喜欢动作人偶。
When I was a kid, they were my gateway to another world. After while I didn't even have to play with them, I just hold my Luke Skywalker action figure and go into a catatonic state. My parents used to say I was looking out. As far as I knew, movies and TV shows aimed at kids always came with action figures. That's the way things were. But when George Lucas pitched the idea of Star Wars action figures to toy companies in 1976, a lot of companies turned him down. Except for one company in Cincinnati, Kenner.
当我还是个孩子的时候，它们是我通往另一个世界的门户。过了一段时间，我甚至不需要玩它们，我只是拿着我的卢克·天行者动作人偶，进入一种紧张性精神症状态。我父母过去常说我是在发呆。据我所知，针对儿童的电影和电视节目总是附带动作人偶。事情本来就是这样。但当乔治·卢卡斯在1976年向玩具公司推销《星球大战》动作人偶的想法时，许多公司拒绝了他。除了辛辛那提的一家公司——肯纳。
Kenner ended up minting money with those Star Wars toys. The other companies must have been jealous. But Star Wars was a phenomenon. I mean, how do you reverse engineer that? They could wait until the next Star Wars fell into their laps, but there's only one George Lucas. And the toy companies were getting burned by filmmakers claiming to have the next Star Wars, but the movies were flops and the toys sat on shelves. If only the toy companies could make their own media, you know, TV shows that star the toys that they want to sell, well, they're about to get a helping hand from Ronald Reagan. One of Reagan's main goals was
肯纳最终靠那些《星球大战》玩具赚得盆满钵满。其他公司一定很嫉妒。但《星球大战》是一个现象级作品。我的意思是，你怎么能逆向工程呢？他们可以等待下一个《星球大战》掉进他们的怀里，但乔治·卢卡斯只有一个。玩具公司被那些声称拥有下一个《星球大战》的电影制作人坑惨了，但电影票房惨败，玩具堆在货架上。如果玩具公司能制作自己的媒体，你知道，就是让他们想卖的玩具担任主角的电视节目，那么，他们即将得到罗纳德·里根的帮助。里根的主要目标之一是
deregulation. In 1983 and 84, government agencies that monitor advertising and content in children's television declared that the marketplace should decide what gets put on the air, not the government. But even though Reagan was creating this very corporate friendly environment, the toy companies didn't know how to take advantage of it at first. They didn't have a master plan on how to conquer the minds of kids to get us to convince our parents that our entire happiness depended on getting that new toy. And I can say this from personal experience,
放松管制。在1983年和1984年，监管儿童电视广告和内容的政府机构宣布，市场应该决定什么节目可以播出，而不是政府。但尽管里根创造了这种非常有利于企业的环境，玩具公司起初并不知道如何利用它。他们没有征服孩子头脑的总体规划，无法让我们说服父母，我们的全部幸福都取决于得到那个新玩具。我可以从个人经验说，
it was dangerous to bring me to Toys R Us because I would beg my mom that I really, really, really needed that new action figure and she'd say, but don't you have a lot of those toys? No, well, okay, fine, I have that guy and that guy and that guy but I don't have this guy. From an adult perspective it's easy to get very cynical about this. But Isaac Elliott Fisher is a documentary filmmaker who's made films about toys, he's also a toy designer and he runs a toy store in Ontario. He says there's a misconception that kids would want anything
带我去玩具反斗城是很危险的，因为我会求我妈妈，我真的、真的、真的需要那个新的动作人偶，她会说，你不是有很多那种玩具吗？不，好吧，好吧，我有那个家伙、那个家伙和那个家伙，但我没有这个家伙。从成年人的角度来看，很容易对此持怀疑态度。但艾萨克·埃利奥特·费舍尔是一位纪录片制作人，他制作过关于玩具的电影，他也是一名玩具设计师，并在安大略省经营一家玩具店。他说，人们有一种误解，认为孩子们会想要你放在电视上的任何东西。
you put on TV. You had to be really good to rise to the top. You had to be good designers. You had to be good writers. There had to be a certain level of disassociation between the writer and the cartoon company and the toys, not based on regulation, but based on if you wanted this to be good, it had to be written well. After turning down Star Wars, a lot of toy companies were now in the position of trying to compete with Star Wars. Mattel was one of the first companies to figure it out, and they kind of fell into it.
你必须非常出色才能脱颖而出。你必须是优秀的设计师。你必须是优秀的编剧。编剧、动画公司和玩具之间必须有一定的脱节，这不是基于监管，而是基于如果你想让它变得出色，它就必须写得好。在拒绝了《星球大战》之后，许多玩具公司现在处于试图与《星球大战》竞争的位置。美泰是第一批弄明白这一点的公司之一，而且他们算是误打误撞进来的。
In the early 80s, people at Mattel were brainstorming ideas, and one of their concept guys, named Roger Sweet, pitched a bunch of characters which got rejected. things with boys, barbarian theme seems to be the thing. So if we take barbarian cone in and mix it with Star Wars, that'll be the thing. But Star Wars had a story. He-Man did not. They don't know how to tell the story, so the guys, the marketing guys just come up with stupid names like, we're gonna have like He-Man and then D-Man instead of Skeletor, wasn't that? And he's like, and C-Man, and then they got somebody else in the office is like, no, you should try it, Merman.
80年代初，美泰的人在头脑风暴，他们的一位概念设计师罗杰·斯威特提出了很多角色，但都被拒绝了。男孩们喜欢野蛮人主题。所以如果我们把野蛮人柯南和《星球大战》结合起来，那就会火。但《星球大战》有故事。希曼没有。他们不知道怎么讲故事，所以营销人员只是想出一些愚蠢的名字，比如，我们要有希曼，然后是D-Man，而不是骷髅王，不是吗？他说，还有C-Man，然后办公室里的另一个人说，不，你应该试试Merman（鱼人）。
Yeah, Merman, that's better than C-Man, that's good. Woeman was one of them. Nope, no, Kenneth Woeman will call or teal it. There's actually a very complicated backstory as to which people deserve credit for coming up with He-Man and the other aspects of the Masters of the Universe line. But that's the nature of these corporate products. Everybody has a hand in it, but ultimately, everything they do is for Mattel. Mattel also commissioned many comic books that came with the toys to explain who the characters were,
是的，鱼人，那比C-Man好，那很好。Woeman是其中之一。不，不，肯尼斯·沃曼会叫或者叫它Teal。关于谁应该因创造希曼和宇宙大师系列的其他方面而获得赞誉，实际上有一个非常复杂的背景故事。但这就是这些企业产品的本质。每个人都参与其中，但最终，他们所做的一切都是为了美泰。美泰还委托制作了许多随玩具附赠的漫画书，以解释这些角色是谁，
and they made commercials with a company called Filmation. Who's the big guy with the muscles? He's he man, the most powerful man in the universe. And you were allowed to have X amount of animated fantasy content within a toy commercial. So you had to have certain percentage of it be real world. So it's like a dad and his kids going, I let my kids play with Castle Grace Call from Mattel. And then it's like they have this little animated bit in the middle and it's somewhere in there. Lou Scheimer at Filmation said,
他们还与一家名为Filmation的公司制作了广告。那个肌肉发达的大个子是谁？他是希曼，宇宙中最强大的人。在玩具广告中，你被允许包含一定数量的动画奇幻内容。所以你必须有一定比例是现实世界的。就像一个爸爸和他的孩子们说，我让我的孩子们玩美泰的格雷斯库尔城堡。然后中间有一小段动画，就在那里。Filmation的卢·谢默说，
well, hey, this could be a show. And the masters of the universe. It's amazing to me how little coordination there was. The people who designed the toys had no idea what was in the cartoon until it was done. So these guys were like all over the map, whether it was a cartoon or a media product or anything, they were just things were happening so quickly, even though Mattel owned the block of time that was then syndicated for that cartoon. So they could sell the commercial spots even to themselves and make more money off those commercial spots than the show. Even though they were paying essentially for that cartoon to happen, the
嘿，这可以做成一个节目。还有宇宙大师。令我惊讶的是，协调工作竟然如此之少。设计玩具的人在动画片完成之前根本不知道里面有什么。所以这些人就像无头苍蝇一样，无论是动画片还是媒体产品，事情发生得太快了，尽管美泰拥有后来为该动画片联合播出的时间段。所以他们甚至可以把广告位卖给自己，从这些广告位赚的钱比节目本身还多。尽管他们本质上是在为那部动画片的制作买单，但
writers worked for filmation. So you had these layers of separation. The comics that Mattel commissioned were more serious and action-packed. The cartoon had goofy humor and life lessons at the end of each episode. The He-Man cartoon launched in the fall of 1983. It was a huge hit. The toys had been around for a year, but suddenly their sales skyrocketed. There's actually a word for this phenomenon. Toyetic. Toyetic refers to a media property where there's so much overlap between the toys, the content, and the advertising that you don't know where one begins and the other ends. In 1984, I was aging out of the demographic of children that these companies were trying to reach.
编剧为Filmation工作。所以你有了这些分离层。美泰委托制作的漫画更严肃、动作更多。动画片在每集结尾都有滑稽的幽默和人生教训。希曼动画片于1983年秋季推出。它非常成功。玩具已经存在一年了，但突然间销量飙升。实际上有一个词来形容这种现象。Toyetic（玩具化）。Toyetic指的是一种媒体属性，玩具、内容和广告之间的重叠非常多，以至于你不知道从哪里开始，到哪里结束。1984年，我正逐渐超出这些公司试图触及的儿童人口统计范围。
But, I was very aware of what the new toys and cartoons were. And I remember reading opinion pieces from concerned parents who were saying, this is awful. We're opening the floodgates of visual junk food for kids. And I remember thinking, what's wrong with that? In part three of our mini series on iconic works that came out in 1984, we're going to look at two toyetic franchises that launched 40 years ago. Transformers and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. They dominated TV and toy stores for years.
但是，我非常清楚什么是新的玩具和动画片。我记得读过一些忧心忡忡的父母写的评论文章，他们说，这太糟糕了。我们正在为孩子们打开视觉垃圾食品的闸门。我记得当时想，这有什么错吗？在我们关于1984年标志性作品的迷你剧第三部分中，我们将看看40年前推出的两个玩具化系列。《变形金刚》和《忍者神龟》。它们统治了电视和玩具店多年。
But each property struggled with the same question. What happens when the merchandise you sell to promote a story starts driving the story? Or to put it another way, when the cart comes before the horse, are you still going anywhere? Let's stay in 1983 for a little bit longer. The industry now had a clear business plan, and Mattel was not the only company to figure it out. Hasbro took a similar approach with GI Joe. They combined a new toy line with comics and a cartoon show, and they gave Star Wars a run for its money. But Hasbro wasn't satisfied. They wanted to find another franchise that they could launch in 1984.
但每个项目都面临着同样的问题。当你为了推销故事而销售的商品开始驱动故事时，会发生什么？或者换句话说，当本末倒置时，你还能走得远吗？让我们在1983年多待一会儿。该行业现在有了明确的商业计划，美泰并不是唯一一家弄明白这一点的公司。孩之宝在《特种部队》上也采取了类似的方法。他们将新的玩具系列与漫画和动画片结合起来，并让《星球大战》感受到了压力。但孩之宝并不满足。他们想找到另一个可以在1984年推出的系列。
And there's one way to do it very quickly. Look to Japan, which had its own booming toy market. So Hasbro made a deal with a Japanese company called Takara Tomi. They made these robots that could turn into vehicles and other objects. The execs at Hasbro thought, we could rebrand those and sell them in the US. They hired an ad agency to come up with a new name for the toys, Transformers. The agency also came up with the names of the good guys and the bad guys, Autobots and Decepticons. And of course, Hasbro wanted to have a comic book and
有一种方法可以很快做到。看看日本，那里有自己蓬勃发展的玩具市场。所以孩之宝与一家名为Takara Tomy的日本公司达成了协议。他们制造了这些可以变成车辆和其他物体的机器人。孩之宝的高管们想，我们可以重塑品牌并在美国销售。他们聘请了一家广告公司为这些玩具想出一个新名字：变形金刚。该公司还想出了好人和坏人的名字：汽车人和霸天虎。当然，孩之宝想要一本漫画书和
a TV show to go with their new property. So they hired Marvel to create a series of comics which would explain who the characters were. Hasbro didn't even know who the characters were. who the characters were. Hasbro didn't even know who the characters were. So what was going on at Marvel at the time? Now remember this is way before the MCU. Their focus, comic books. And they were going to launch a huge crossover event in 1984 called Secret Wars. The character Venom was first introduced in those comics. Who would rather write comics for a toy company instead? There were not many takers at Marvel. But Bob Budiansky was interested. You know, any opportunity at Marvel, to my mind, was a good opportunity. One thing would always lead to the next thing. So getting a gig, writing a toy book is the same to me
一部电视节目来配合他们的新资产。所以他们聘请漫威创作了一系列漫画，解释这些角色是谁。孩之宝甚至不知道这些角色是谁。那么当时漫威在发生什么呢？记住，这远在漫威电影宇宙之前。他们的重点是漫画书。他们将在1984年发起一场名为《秘密战争》的大型交叉事件。角色毒液就是在那部漫画中首次引入的。谁愿意为玩具公司写漫画呢？漫威里没几个人愿意。但鲍勃·布迪安斯基感兴趣。你知道，在我看来，漫威的任何机会都是好机会。一件事总会引向下一件事。所以得到一份写玩具书的工作对我来说
as anything else. It's a stepping stone to the next place. The treatment had already gone through another writer. Everything that writer came up with had been rejected, except for one thing. Bob's editor liked one of the names the other writer had come up with. Optimus Prime. So in November of 1983, Bob was sitting in his office. His editor came in and dumped a box of toys on his desk.
和任何其他工作一样。它是通往下一个地方的垫脚石。这个方案已经经过了另一位编剧的手。那位编剧想出的所有东西都被拒绝了，只有一件事除外。鲍勃的编辑喜欢另一位编剧想出的名字之一：擎天柱。所以1983年11月，鲍勃坐在办公室里。他的编辑走进来，把一盒玩具倒在他的桌子上。
There's a weekend right before Thanksgiving, and he said, these are the bad guys. These are the good guys. Can you develop 26 characters over this weekend? Meaning coming up with their names and their character profiles. So I said, yeah, sure, I can do that. All right, so let's go through the names. How did you come? Tell me about the names. The Megatron, of course, we're going to start with him. Okay. Well, Megatron, actually Megatron is a good name to start with because probably of all the names I came up with, and I came up with about 250 names over the years, that's probably my favorite. And I came up with that, you know, right from the get-go. At the time,
那是感恩节前的一个周末，他说，这些是坏人。这些是好人。你能在周末开发26个角色吗？意思是想出他们的名字和角色简介。我说，是的，当然，我可以做到。好吧，那我们来看看名字。你是怎么想出来的？告诉我关于名字的事。威震天，当然，我们要从他开始。好吧。嗯，威震天，实际上威震天是一个很好的名字，因为在我多年来想出的所有名字中，这可能是我最喜欢的。我从一开始就想到了它。当时，
back in the mid-1980s, the term mega mega the connotation for that was kind of negative because it was associated with megatons And megaton with the word that to describe the destructive power of nuclear bombs and Tron was just your standard Suffix having to do with electronics or technology So I just put the two words together mega Tron and I thought that sounds really good as a nice melodic sound to it and it has this feeling of danger and some kind of threatening character and so that was a name where I Like all the names had to run it by Hasbro. They had to make the final decision They had to make sure the legal department approved it so and so so on. And that was a name that, to my surprise, Hasbro rejected, but not for any legal reasons.
回到80年代中期，Mega这个词的内涵有点负面，因为它与百万吨级有关。百万吨级是描述核弹破坏力的词，而Tron只是一个与电子或技术有关的标准后缀。所以我只是把这两个词放在一起：威震天。我觉得它听起来很好，有一种悦耳的声音，而且有一种危险和某种威胁性的感觉。所以这是一个我必须让孩之宝过目的名字。他们必须做出最终决定。他们必须确保法律部门批准它，等等。令我惊讶的是，孩之宝拒绝了这个名字，但不是因为任何法律原因。
So I actually spoke to my liaison over at Hasbro, and I said, so Megatron, why did you guys decide to reject it? And the answer was, well, we thought about it, and we thought it sounded too scary. And I was kind of surprised at that, because as I kind of gently pointed out to them, he's the leader of the bad guys, he should sound like a very scary character. They thought about it and they said, yeah, you're right, we'll go with
所以我实际上和孩之宝的联络人谈过，我说，那么威震天，为什么你们决定拒绝它？答案是，嗯，我们考虑了一下，觉得它听起来太可怕了。我对此感到有点惊讶，因为正如我委婉地向他们指出的那样，他是坏人的首领，他听起来应该是一个非常可怕的角色。他们考虑了一下，说，是的，你是对的，我们就用
Megatron. So I saved Megatron. Now we're going to publish the purpose of our little visit, the total destruction of our helpless souls. Another breakout character that Bob came up with was Bumblebee. So Bumblebee started out as a VW bug. The toy was painted yellow and black and it was small. So I was looking for a name that had the connections to yellow and black, small, a bug. But I didn't want him to look to sound like a complete weakling, because even though he was small, he was part of the U-Auto box.
威震天。所以我保住了威震天。现在我们要发布我们这次小访问的目的，彻底摧毁我们无助的灵魂。鲍勃想出的另一个突破性角色是大黄蜂。所以大黄蜂最初是一辆大众甲壳虫。玩具被漆成黄色和黑色，而且很小。所以我一直在寻找一个与黄色和黑色、小、虫子有关的名字。但我不想让他听起来像个彻底的弱者，因为尽管他很小，但他属于汽车人。
He was a fighter. I thought, well, Bumblebee's a good name to associate all those different qualities. You sure we did the right thing in coming here, Bumblebee? No, but we can hardly stay behind either. Come on. They launched the franchise in 1984. Would they get their He-Man moment?
他是个战士。我想，嗯，大黄蜂是一个很好的名字，可以把所有这些不同的品质联系起来。你确定我们来这里是对的吗，大黄蜂？不，但我们也不能留在后面。走吧。他们在1984年推出了这个系列。他们会迎来他们的希曼时刻吗？
Do they put all the pieces in place? Of course they did. Now everything that Bob established in the comics was canon, and then those comics were sent to the animation company, so they knew who the characters were. But they could come up with their own storylines for the cartoon show. And after that, I had no connection
他们把所有部分都准备好了吗？当然准备好了。现在鲍勃在漫画中建立的一切都是正史，然后这些漫画被送到动画公司，所以他们知道角色是谁。但他们可以为动画片想出自己的故事情节。在那之后，我与
to the animated series. In my entire life, I've never sat down and watched one single episode of what was going on. Which is amazing to me because I remember this show being all over TV. Although I actually haven't listened to the song in almost 40 years and I cannot believe how good it is. I love the minor chords and the harmonizing. It actually makes me feel like the stakes are high in this battle of good versus evil?
动画系列没有任何联系。在我的一生中，我从来没有坐下来看过一集正在发生的事情。这令我感到惊讶，因为我记得这个节目在电视上到处都是。虽然我实际上已经快40年没听过这首歌了，我简直不敢相信它有多好。我喜欢小调和声。它真的让我觉得在这场善恶之战中赌注很高？
And of course they use the song in the commercials, along with the animation from the show, until the live-action kids suddenly appeared, playing with the toys. I remember talking to a Hasbro executive at the time I was working in Transformers, and she said that if a toy comes out and lasts two holiday seasons, in other words, it's introduced in the fall of the year, right before Christmas holidays and so on. If it lasts two holiday seasons, that's considered a success in the toy industry. Two holiday seasons later, Transformers was not slowing down. But Hasbro was not going to feel content. They say if your business isn't growing, it's dying. And they felt an imperative to keep adding new characters and new toys.
当然，他们在广告中使用了这首歌，以及节目中的动画，直到真人孩子突然出现，玩着玩具。我记得在为《变形金刚》工作时，我曾与一位孩之宝高管交谈，她说如果一个玩具出来并持续了两个假期，换句话说，它在一年秋天推出，就在圣诞假期之前等等。如果它持续了两个假期，那在玩具行业就被认为是成功的。两个假期后，《变形金刚》并没有放缓。但孩之宝不会感到满足。他们说如果你的生意不增长，它就在死亡。他们感到有必要不断增加新角色和新玩具。
And all of these new characters had to be introduced in the comics. I had to come up with all different ways of finding access into the story life of all these new characters. Like, they're on characters. Like they're on earth, but they're on Cybertron. How do these guys on Cybertron is distant planet, all of a sudden show up in my storyline on earth. I came up with something called the creation matrix. Like how do these mechanical life forms come up with new mechanical life forms? They don't, they're asexual, they don't reproduce like we do. So the Creation Matrix was basically
所有这些新角色都必须在漫画中引入。我必须想出各种方法来寻找进入所有这些新角色生活故事的途径。比如，他们在地球上，但他们在塞伯坦。这些在遥远星球塞伯坦上的家伙怎么会突然出现在我在地球上的故事情节中。我想出了一种叫做“领导模块”的东西。这些机械生命形式是如何产生新的机械生命形式的？他们不产生，他们是无性的，他们不像我们那样繁殖。所以领导模块基本上
a very sophisticated program that the leader of the auto box had access to. And through that Creation Matrix, he can create new mechanical life. Another way was I created a space bridge. So this was a bridge that went from Cybertron through some kind of a wormhole or something and landed on Earth.
是一个非常复杂的程序，汽车人的领袖可以访问它。通过那个领导模块，他可以创造新的机械生命。另一种方式是我创造了一个太空桥。所以这是一座从塞伯坦穿过某种虫洞之类的东西，然后降落在地球上的桥。
Was that a challenge in terms of, you know, you're writing your stories, you're planning things out and they're like, here's a bunch of new characters, we're selling these toys, you need to incorporate this into your scripts? Well, first of all, that describes almost to a T exactly where Hasbro was coming from. Yes. They looked at the comic book as a vehicle to market their toys, to sell more toys. It became more and more of a burden to come up with new ways to introduce all these new
在写故事、计划事情时，这是一个挑战吗？他们说，这是一堆新角色，我们正在卖这些玩具，你需要把这个融入到你的剧本中？嗯，首先，这几乎完全描述了孩之宝的立场。是的。他们把漫画书看作是推销玩具、卖更多玩具的工具。想出新方法来引入所有这些新
toys. And also, simultaneously, I was writing stories that featured certain characters, and then I'd have to kind of gently push them aside because I needed to make space for all these other characters that I wanted to introduce in the story. When it came to the animation, Hasbro did not gently push the characters aside. They made the decision to kill off many of the characters introduced in the 1984 toy line so they could clear the shelves for the next line of toys.
玩具变得越来越是一种负担。而且，同时，我正在写以某些角色为主角的故事，然后我不得不委婉地把他们推到一边，因为我需要为我想在故事中引入的所有其他角色腾出空间。当谈到动画时，孩之宝并没有委婉地把角色推到一边。他们决定杀死1984年玩具系列中引入的许多角色，以便为下一系列玩具清理货架。
And they killed them off in the first half hour of the animated Transformers movie. off in the first half hour of the animated Transformers movie. But kids didn't think of these characters as just toys. They were sobbing in the theaters. And all of this product churned to Catole and Bob as well. I was burnt out. I was trying to get off the book for probably up to a year before that. My editor kept begging me, please stay on the book because I don't know who else I can
他们在动画版《变形金刚》电影的前半小时内就把他们杀死了。但孩子们并不认为这些角色只是玩具。他们在电影院里啜泣。所有这些产品也让鲍勃感到厌倦。我精疲力竭了。在那之前，我可能已经尝试了一年要退出这本书。我的编辑一直求我，请留在书上，因为我不知道还能找谁
get to write this thing. He finally found a replacement in 1989, but at that point the franchise was losing steam. He thought he put Transformers behind him. And then in 2004, In the first Transformers convention I went to, I like to describe it as my Elvis moment. A young man was walking by and he says, It's you. You're him, you're him. And I realized then, yeah, I did something really special. I take a sense of pride in the fact that these stories and these characters that I wrote now almost 40 years ago
来写这个东西。他终于在1989年找到了替代者，但那时这个系列已经失去了动力。他以为他把《变形金刚》抛在了身后。然后在2004年，在我参加的第一个《变形金刚》大会上，我喜欢把它描述为我的“猫王时刻”。一个年轻人走过来，他说，是你。你是他，你是他。我那时意识到，是的，我做了一些非常特别的事情。我为我几乎40年前写下的这些故事和这些角色感到自豪，
are still around and the people still really care about it. Although he doesn't feel a sense of ownership over it. I mean, he literally doesn't own it. I was a cog in the machine. I was, if they, if they didn't choose me to develop those characters and I've ultimately write the comic book, Marvel would have found somebody else. It just happened to be me. And in fact, I wasn't even the first choice or the second choice.
它们仍然存在，人们仍然非常关心它。虽然他并没有感到一种所有权。我的意思是，他实际上并不拥有它。我是机器里的一个齿轮。如果他们没有选择我来开发这些角色并最终写漫画书，漫威会找到别人的。碰巧是我而已。事实上，我甚至不是第一选择或第二选择。
I was like about the fourth or fifth choice. But that's the way it goes with the toyatic franchises. How could it have gone any differently? Coming up, the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles enter the stage after this. We're back with Imaginary Worlds on 99% Invisible. Let me tell you another story. A story that ends up in the same place, but it begins with very humble origins. And this story does not start with a top-down corporate strategy and everybody working in their separate silos. It doesn't start with ideas being focus-grouped and market-tested.
我大概是第四或第五选择。但这就是玩具化系列的发展方式。怎么可能有什么不同呢？接下来，在广告之后，《忍者神龟》登场。我们带着《虚构世界》回到《99%隐形》。让我再讲一个故事。一个以同样地方结束的故事，但它始于非常卑微的起源。这个故事不是从自上而下的企业战略和每个人在各自的孤岛中工作开始的。它不是从焦点小组和市场测试的想法开始的。
And it doesn't involve company employees who share a tiny bit of the credit and even less of the profits. Let's rewind our VHS cassette of time back to 1983. We're no longer in a corporate headquarters in a major city. We're now in a small town in New Hampshire at the headquarters of Mirage Studios, which is actually in somebody's house. The name Mirage was itself kind of a, you know, a joke and a commentary in the studio because they didn't actually have a professional studio space. They didn't have anybody working for them other than those two guys, Kevin and Peter. That is Andrew Farago. He is the curator of the Cartoon Art Museum in San Francisco,
它也不涉及分享一点点功劳甚至更少利润的公司员工。让我们把时间的录像带倒回到1983年。我们不再是在大城市的企业总部。我们现在是在新罕布什尔州一个小镇的幻影工作室总部，实际上是在某人的家里。幻影这个名字本身就是一种玩笑和评论，因为他们实际上没有专业的工作室空间。除了那两个家伙，凯文和彼得，他们没有雇佣任何人。那是安德鲁·法拉戈。他是旧金山卡通艺术博物馆的馆长，
and he's written several books about cartoons and comics. The Kevin and Peter that he's referring to are Kevin Eastman and Peter Laird. Andrew says one night in 1983, Kevin and Peter were working at their desks. It was late. They were getting antsy, they needed a break. So they decided let's do one of our usual things and just try to crack each other up. So one of them hit upon the idea of you know I'm gonna draw a goofy turtle character, let's take a turtle, outfit him as a ninja, give him some weapons. They kept adding to it so they drew extra. And by the end of the night, they had actually hit upon the name
他写过几本关于卡通和漫画的书。他提到的凯文和彼得是凯文·伊斯特曼和彼得·莱尔德。安德鲁说，1983年的一天晚上，凯文和彼得在办公桌前工作。天很晚了。他们变得焦躁不安，需要休息。所以他们决定做我们通常做的事情之一，只是试着逗对方笑。所以其中一个人想到了一个主意，你知道，我要画一个滑稽的乌龟角色，让我们拿一只乌龟，把他打扮成忍者，给他一些武器。他们不断增加内容，所以他们画了额外的。到晚上结束时，他们实际上已经想到了名字
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. Then they realized, this is actually kind of cool. We can make a comic book about this. In 1984, they were ready to bring their comic to a local comic convention in Portsmouth, New Hampshire. To get some attention, they put out a press release. Touting the fact that this was as far as they knew the first professional comic book created and printed in New Hampshire, the combination of that really unforgettable title,
《忍者神龟》。然后他们意识到，这其实挺酷的。我们可以为此制作一本漫画书。1984年，他们准备把他们的漫画带到新罕布什尔州朴茨茅斯的一个当地漫画大会上。为了引起注意，他们发布了一份新闻稿。吹嘘这是他们所知的第一个在新罕布什尔州创作和印刷的专业漫画书，那个令人难忘的标题的组合，
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. And fortunately for them, a slow news day, the Associated Press picked up on it. And just like that, coast to coast, their pictures were in the newspaper. Before the convention even happened, they'd heard from comic book stores nationwide who wanted to order copies of this for their shops. Earlier, we heard from Isaac Elliott Fisher. He's currently working on his second documentary about teenage mutant ninja turtles. They only printed 3,000 copies of the first issue, and they sell out very, very quickly. And they thought they were like they always said they thought they were going to be burning them to keep warm that winter.
《忍者神龟》。幸运的是，那天新闻很少，美联社报道了它。就这样，从东海岸到西海岸，他们的照片出现在报纸上。在大会召开之前，他们就已经收到了全国各地漫画店的消息，他们想为他们的商店订购副本。早些时候，我们听到了艾萨克·埃利奥特·费舍尔的声音。他目前正在制作他的第二部关于《忍者神龟》的纪录片。他们只印刷了3000本第一期，很快就卖光了。他们以为，他们总是说，他们以为那个冬天他们会烧掉它们来取暖。
I mean, they killed their main bad guy in the first book. I mean, Shredder is killed in the first issue. They never intended on doing another one. But at some point when they had sold out very quickly and they were doing another printing, they went, wait a minute, they did the math, they wrote it down, they said, if we did a book every two months or whatever, we could make like $2,000 each per book. And that was huge. You know, for them, they were making like $4,000 a year if they were lucky. They hired a few more artists, and Mirage Studios was no longer a Mirage. It was a fully-fledged
我的意思是，他们在第一本书里就杀死了他们的主要反派。我的意思是，施莱德在第一期就被杀了。他们从来没打算再做一本。但在某个时候，当他们很快卖光并进行第二次印刷时，他们想，等一下，他们算了算，写下来，他们说，如果我们每两个月做一本书，我们每本书每人能赚2000美元。那太棒了。你知道，对他们来说，如果幸运的话，他们一年能赚4000美元。他们又雇了几个艺术家，幻影工作室不再是幻影。它是一个成熟的
studio. A few years later, a business entrepreneur named Mark Friedman arranged a meeting with Kevin and Peter. Andrew says Mark was a lot like them. He was an up-and-comer who punched above his weight. And he thought the turtles could be the next transformers. Mark approached them and I think we've got something here. Let me have turtles for a month. Let me take it out to the West Coast, shop it around, see what I can do. If you're happy with what I'm doing, we'll keep it going. If not, we'll part ways. No hard feelings. They said, sure, you've got the enthusiasm, you're excited about us. We're not really thinking about anything beyond the comic book at this point anyway, so go for it.
工作室。几年后，一位名叫马克·弗里德曼的商业企业家安排了与凯文和彼得的会面。安德鲁说马克和他们很像。他是一个超越自己能力的后起之秀。他认为乌龟可能是下一个《变形金刚》。马克接近他们，我想我们在这里有东西了。让我拿乌龟一个月。让我把它带到西海岸，到处推销，看看我能做什么。如果你对我的做法满意，我们就继续。如果不满意，我们就分道扬镳。没有硬感情。他们说，当然，你有热情，你对我们很兴奋。反正我们当时并没有考虑漫画书以外的任何事情，所以去做吧。
Oh, they said one more thing. If you sell this to toy companies or whatever, we still retain full ownership. And he said, okay, that'll be part of the deal. Mark Freeman went out to pitch what was going to become the next toyetic phenomenon. And it didn't go well. Although I can imagine the perspective of the toy companies. The comic book was gritty. It was not aimed at young kids. The word teenage was right in the title. And speaking of the title, mutants come from nuclear waste, ninjas are violent, turtles are slow and boring. Whoever thought you could actually sell this to kids? He finally found a company that was interested. Playmates had success making dolls and they wanted to break into the action figure market.
哦，他们又说了一件事。如果你把它卖给玩具公司什么的，我们仍然保留完全的所有权。他说，好的，那将是交易的一部分。马克·弗里德曼出去推销即将成为下一个玩具化现象的东西。结果并不顺利。虽然我可以想象玩具公司的视角。漫画书很坚韧。它不是针对小孩子的。标题里就有“青少年”这个词。说到标题，变种人来自核废料，忍者是暴力的，乌龟是缓慢而无聊的。谁会想到你真的能把这个卖给孩子？他终于找到了一家感兴趣的公司。Playmates在制作玩偶方面取得了成功，他们想打入动作人偶市场。
He had a convincing pitch. He explained, this is the potential I see in turtles. It could be the next He-Man. It could be the next Masters of the Universe, G.I. Joe, Transformers. Playmates bought the pitch. Now they needed a cartoon show because that's how you launch a toy-etic franchise. Remember how the designers at Mattel had no connection with the He-Man cartoon show? Bob Budianski never saw the Transformers cartoon show. When playmates developed a cartoon show for turtles, Peter Laird and Kevin Eastman
他有一个令人信服的推销。他解释说，这就是我在乌龟身上看到的潜力。它可能是下一个希曼。它可能是下一个宇宙大师、《特种部队》、《变形金刚》。Playmates买下了这个推销。现在他们需要一部动画片，因为这就是你如何推出一个玩具化系列的方法。还记得美泰的设计师与希曼动画片没有任何联系吗？鲍勃·布迪安斯基从未看过《变形金刚》动画片。当Playmates为乌龟开发动画片时，彼得·莱尔德和凯文·伊斯特曼
were in all of those meetings. They still own the whole thing. And when Isaac was working on his first documentary about the turtles, Peter Laird gave him access to footage from that time. Kevin and Peter get brought into these boardroomings and Peter records the whole darn thing on camera every time. And they let him? Yeah. And it's so fascinating because all of this
参加了所有这些会议。他们仍然拥有整个东西。当艾萨克制作他的第一部关于乌龟的纪录片时，彼得·莱尔德让他接触了那个时期的录像。凯文和彼得被带进这些董事会会议，彼得每次都在摄像机上记录整个过程。他们让他这么做？是的。这太迷人了，因为所有这些
is creative process. So it's iterative. What if we did this? What if we did that? What if, because the turtles in the comic books were black and white, they all looked exactly the same. And if they were in color, they all had red bandanas. So how are kids gonna tell them apart? Well, let's make them all different colors.
都是创作过程。所以它是迭代的。如果我们这样做呢？如果我们那样做呢？如果，因为漫画书里的乌龟是黑白的，它们看起来完全一样。如果它们是彩色的，它们都戴着红色的头巾。那么孩子们怎么区分它们呢？嗯，让我们让它们都变成不同的颜色。
Great idea, let's put different initials on the belt buckles. And at the time, they were convinced that the playmates was designing ideas of all the bad guys should be these human-esque bad guys. And Shredder's a good bad guy, so we'll bring back Shredder. But all of his henchmen should be like angry mutated dudes from New York, like a taxi driver or a mechanic with a wrench for an arm.
好主意，让我们在皮带扣上放不同的首字母。当时，他们确信Playmates正在设计所有坏人的想法应该是这些类人的坏人。施莱德是一个好的坏人，所以我们会带回施莱德。但他所有的手下都应该是来自纽约的愤怒的变异家伙，比如出租车司机或手臂上拿着扳手的机械师。
And Peter kept saying on camera in these meetings, he kept saying, what if they were like mutants in human clothing? Like what if they were wearing like khaki pants or camo or something? And he was drawing mutant rhino and a mutant warthog. He was drawing Bebop and rocksteady in those meetings. Bebop and rocksteady are henchmen of the main villain, Shredder.
彼得在这些会议上一直对着镜头说，他一直说，如果他们是穿着人类衣服的变种人呢？比如如果他们穿着卡其裤或迷彩服之类的东西呢？他当时正在画变异犀牛和变异疣猪。他在那些会议上画了比博和洛克史迪。比博和洛克史迪是主要反派施莱德的手下。
Well, well, well, lookie what we found. We got a squad to settle with you little toyps. The amazing thing to me is that Peter and Kevin were not precious about this world they created. You need us to age it down for younger kids? No problem. Just let us in the meetings. But Andrew says they didn't foresee how huge this was going to be. They thought it would bring in some extra work, some extra cash. Andrew This was great because they could make comic books, they could draw all day, they could employ even more artists, even more friends of theirs.
好吧，好吧，看看我们发现了什么。我们有一支小队要和你这些小乌龟算账。令我惊讶的是，彼得和凯文并不珍视他们创造的这个世界。你需要我们为更小的孩子降低年龄吗？没问题。只要让我们参加会议就行。但安德鲁说，他们没有预见到这会有多大。他们以为这会带来一些额外的工作，一些额外的现金。安德鲁，这太棒了，因为他们可以制作漫画书，他们可以整天画画，他们可以雇佣更多的艺术家，更多的朋友。
When that cartoon and that toy line launched teenage mutant ninja turtles went from niche to ubiquitous almost overnight. Turtles fight with honor! Move over He-Man, move over Transformers. Those shells are going to be dominated by turtles for years to come. Take cover! The footer attacking with their sewer ball! Watch out turtles or you'll wind up in the recovery room! Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles! From Playmate!
当那部动画片和那个玩具系列推出时，《忍者神龟》几乎在一夜之间从小众变成了无处不在。乌龟带着荣誉战斗！让开希曼，让开《变形金刚》。那些龟壳将在未来几年被乌龟统治。找掩护！脚族正在用他们的下水道球攻击！小心乌龟，否则你会进恢复室的！《忍者神龟》！来自Playmates！
Peter and Kevin wanted to make money, creating something that they love. Be careful what you wish for. The Turtles product line launched in the late 1980s. Isaac says, everything changed for Kevin Eastman and Peter Laird. Multimillion dollar checks were rolling in every single day. Like, Kevin would often say people would think
彼得和凯文想赚钱，创造他们喜欢的东西。小心你所祈求的。乌龟产品系列在80年代末推出。艾萨克说，凯文·伊斯特曼和彼得·莱尔德的一切都变了。数百万美元的支票每天都在滚滚而来。就像，凯文经常说人们会认为
that they would must be cash in checks and sit on a beach somewhere and not doing anything. It's like, no, they were working 90 hour weeks every week. Isaac says before that, they spent most of their time drawing comics. They handled the business maybe 10% of the time. Now. They're doing business 99% of the time
他们一定是在兑现支票，坐在海滩上什么都不做。就像，不，他们每周工作90个小时。艾萨克说，在那之前，他们大部分时间都在画漫画。他们可能10%的时间在处理业务。现在。他们99%的时间都在做生意
and don't have any time to draw anymore. Because all of a sudden you're handling massive, massive amounts of business, because it's like you're a serial company and you wanna put turtles in serial and sell more serial, well, you gotta do all these contracts for that and you have to approve all the art. And now you've gotta take your internal art guys
再也没有时间画画了。因为突然间你正在处理大量大量的业务，因为就像你是一家麦片公司，你想把乌龟放进麦片里卖更多的麦片，好吧，你必须为此做所有的合同，你必须批准所有的艺术。现在你必须把你内部的艺术人员
and make them into marketing art creators because if the serial company wish would often happen, they would kind of do their art, they would send it to them and go, whoa, whoa, no, the turtles aren't purple, what is this? You know, when we were kids consuming every turtle thing, which there were ungodly amount of, every single one of those things
变成营销艺术创作者，因为如果麦片公司经常发生这种情况，他们会做他们的艺术，他们会把它发给他们，然后说，哇，哇，不，乌龟不是紫色的，这是什么？你知道，当我们还是孩子的时候，消费着每一个乌龟的东西，那东西多得不可思议，每一个东西
had to go through Kevin and Peter's hands. And nobody, none of us knew that. None of us thought, oh, there's these two independent comic book guys, we're just like, oh, it's a corporate machine. They were handling the kind of toyotic empire that Hasbro and Mattel had handled, but without the benefit of a corporate structure. And Turtles was arguably bigger at the time because they had a live-action film franchise running alongside the cartoon.
都必须经过凯文和彼得的手。没有人，我们中没有人知道这一点。没有人想，哦，有两个独立的漫画书家伙，我们只是想，哦，这是一个企业机器。他们正在处理孩之宝和美泰处理的那种玩具化帝国，但没有企业结构的好处。而且乌龟在当时可以说更大，因为他们有真人电影系列与动画片同时进行。
The first live-action Turtles movie broke their record for the highest-grossing independent film. According to Isaac, Peter was the more cautious one. He was a little older, he was already settled down. Kevin was more adventurous. He tried out different business ventures that sometimes flopped. He also bought a tank and a Batmobile. And they approached the turtles differently when people came to them with new ideas. Peter would be notorious for the rest of the ownership of the turtles for being very specific, very much hands-on. This needs to be like this. And Kevin was much more open. All of that came to a head in the mid-1990s. The turtle's craze was starting to wind down. The hot new thing were Power Rangers. The company Saban, which made the Power Rangers show, approached Kevin and Peter about doing a
第一部真人乌龟电影打破了他们最高票房独立电影的记录。据艾萨克说，彼得是更谨慎的一个。他稍微大一点，已经安定下来了。凯文更爱冒险。他尝试了有时会失败的不同商业冒险。他还买了一辆坦克和一辆蝙蝠车。当人们带着新想法来找他们时，他们对待乌龟的方式也不同。彼得在乌龟所有权的余下时间里以非常具体、非常亲力亲为而闻名。这需要像这样。而凯文则开放得多。所有这些在90年代中期达到了顶峰。乌龟热潮开始减弱。热门的新事物是《恐龙战队》。制作《恐龙战队》节目的萨班公司接近凯文和彼得，想做一个
live-action Turtles TV show. But Saban wanted to add a fifth turtle character. A girl turtle. This was not a total surprise. Andrew says the toy company and the animation studio had been asking for more turtle characters, especially a girl turtle. But Peter and Kevin didn't really want to deviate from the formula, which had worked so well. So this time around, the studio came to them and they said, we want a girl turtle on this show. And if we don't get it, we're going to walk away. We're not going to do the show. Kevin took them at their word and said, we can keep everybody at Mirage Studios employed. We can keep this going for a while.
真人乌龟电视节目。但萨班想增加第五个乌龟角色。一个女孩乌龟。这并不完全令人惊讶。安德鲁说，玩具公司和动画工作室一直要求更多的乌龟角色，尤其是女孩乌龟。但彼得和凯文并不想偏离那个运作得很好的公式。所以这一次，工作室来找他们说，我们想要这个节目里有一个女孩乌龟。如果我们得不到它，我们就会走人。我们不会做这个节目。凯文听了他们的话说，我们可以让幻影工作室的每个人都保住工作。我们可以让这个节目继续下去。
Maybe this is the little jolt that we need to get the turtles through this kind of market correction or whatever you want to call that. Peter felt that, you know, they were still at that point both the owners of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, and he thought the brand was valuable enough that they didn't have to do that. You know, we can walk away, we can wait for the right opportunity. I don't think this is it.
也许这正是我们需要的一点刺激，让“忍者神龟”度过这种市场调整期，或者随便你怎么称呼它。彼得觉得，你知道，他们当时仍然是《忍者神龟》的共同拥有者，他认为这个品牌非常有价值，他们不必非得那样做。你知道，我们可以退出，我们可以等待合适的时机。我不认为现在是时候。
Kevin convinced Peter to change his mind. Saban went ahead with the show, featuring a girl turtle. You ain't a ninja? show, featuring a girl turtle. The didn't go for it. In fact, at the toy sales, the comic books were kind of at a low point. Everybody was kind of collectively burnt out. Eater Laird, I'm sure, was looking at the situation thinking, you know, we sold out for no reason at all. Eventually, Kevin decided to sell his half of the shares to Peter so he could get out of the business entirely. Peter sold the franchise to Viacom. Peter and Kevin drifted apart,
凯文说服彼得改变了主意。萨班继续制作了这个节目，其中加入了一个女性忍者龟。结果并不理想。事实上，在玩具销售方面，漫画书处于低谷。每个人都感到集体疲惫。我相信彼得·莱尔德当时看着这种情况心想，你知道，我们毫无理由地出卖了自己。最终，凯文决定把他的那一半股份卖给彼得，这样他就可以完全退出这个行业。彼得把特许经营权卖给了维亚康姆。彼得和凯文分道扬镳了，
and they didn't reconcile for years. Meanwhile, the industry was changing. The parents groups who fought against toyetics found a sympathetic ear with the Clinton administration. Limits were set on how much advertising was allowed on children's programming, and they added educational mandates. But Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles did not become a nostalgia brand for adults, at least not entirely.
他们多年没有和解。与此同时，行业正在发生变化。那些反对“玩具化”的家长团体在克林顿政府那里找到了共鸣。儿童节目中允许的广告数量受到了限制，并增加了教育要求。但《忍者神龟》并没有成为一个怀旧品牌，至少不完全是。
Nickelodeon revived the franchise with a series of new shows and movies. The last animated film was produced by Seth Rogen. Woohoo! Hey guys, if we weren't monsters that were shunned by society and we could do what we wanted, what would you guys do? Go to high school, maybe get a girlfriend. Can you imagine that? Not likely.
尼克国际儿童频道通过一系列新节目和电影复兴了这个特许经营权。最后一部动画电影是由塞斯·罗根制作的。“呜呼！嘿伙计们，如果我们不是被社会排斥的怪物，我们可以做任何想做的事，你们会做什么？”“去上高中，也许交个女朋友。你能想象吗？”“不太可能。”
You know, the fact that they have Mutant right in their name, I think, tells you about their ability to adapt and change. And I think, no pun intended, it's such an evergreen property that you're able to take these characters and they never age past their teenage years. So you've got, you always got a new crop of teenagers coming up. You've always got kids who admire and aspire to be teenagers. You know, they'll reboot and they'll kind of take a new fresh approach
你知道，他们的名字里直接带有“变异”这个词，我认为这说明了他们适应和改变的能力。而且我认为，这绝非双关语，这是一个常青的资产，你可以利用这些角色，他们永远不会超过青少年时期。所以你总是有一批新的青少年出现。你总是会有那些钦佩并渴望成为青少年的孩子。你知道，他们会重启，并以一种全新的方式，
roughly every five years, whether they need it or not. Even if they've got a series that's going well, they will put that aside, say, let's bring in some new creators, let's bring in some new perspectives on this. What can we do that's going to be fun and interesting? In 2023, the franchise made a billion dollars in retail sales. But all of that energy wasn't directed towards toys. There were ad campaigns with fast food chains, snack foods, video games, clothing lines. Andrew loved having toys as a kid.
大约每五年一次，不管需不需要。即使他们有一个进展顺利的系列，他们也会将其搁置，说，让我们引入一些新的创作者，让我们对此引入一些新的视角。我们能做些什么既有趣又吸引人呢？2023年，该特许经营权在零售销售额上达到了10亿美元。但所有这些能量并没有全部用于玩具。还有与快餐连锁店、零食、视频游戏、服装系列的广告活动。安德鲁小时候很喜欢玩具。
But he has a different perspective now. As a person with a wallet, I'm really happy that my kid and his friends can just enjoy entertainment and not feel this obligation to buy things. Because I know kids who felt left out in the 80s because their parents weren't buying them every single toy that they saw on TV. They didn't have 100 transformers or go-bots or he-man characters cluttering up their living rooms. Isaac feels a little differently. I mean, his kids are not begging him
但他现在有了不同的看法。作为一个有钱包的人，我真的很高兴我的孩子和他的朋友们可以享受娱乐，而不必感到有购买东西的义务。因为我认识一些在80年代感到被冷落的孩子，因为他们的父母没有给他们买电视上看到的每一个玩具。他们的客厅里没有堆满100个变形金刚、太空堡垒或希曼角色。艾萨克的感觉有点不同。我是说，他的孩子们也没有乞求他
for action figures either, but he actually wants to buy them action figures. And Isaac runs a toy store. Children these days have no access to commercials that give them permission or suggestion to play. And if nothing is on there saying, here's what everybody's into, and here's a commercial showing another kid my age
买人偶，但他实际上想给他们买人偶。艾萨克经营着一家玩具店。现在的孩子无法接触到那些给予他们许可或暗示去玩耍的广告。如果没有任何东西在上面说，这是大家都在玩的东西，这是另一个和我同龄的孩子在玩这个产品的广告，
playing with this product. Now I'm looking at it going, oh, I can do that. So, so often in my store, I'll have adults come in and say, man, I buy action figures from a kid, but they don't know how to play with them. They actually have lost the language of how to do it collectively. Now, they are still making action figures of He-Man,
我现在看着它会想，哦，我也可以那样做。所以，在我的店里，经常会有成年人进来对我说，伙计，我给孩子买人偶，但他们不知道怎么玩。他们实际上已经失去了集体玩耍的语言。现在，他们仍然在制作希曼、
Transformers, and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, and there are action figures of just about every character in Star Wars, DC, and Marvel. But the biggest driver of toy sales today are adults. It's actually called the Kidult Market. And some of these high-end collectible action figures go for hundreds of dollars. Isaac thinks the culture lost something
变形金刚和忍者神龟的人偶，几乎每一个星球大战、DC和漫威的角色都有人偶。但今天玩具销售的最大驱动力是成年人。这实际上被称为“成人儿童市场”。其中一些高端收藏级人偶售价高达数百美元。艾萨克认为文化失去了一些东西，
when that controversial relationship between toy companies, commercial production studios and animation studios was broken apart. And he has a bone to pick with the parents groups who fought to put those regulations in place. Because I mean, we can talk about content, sure. And we want to protect kids from stuff that is, you know, actually violent or actually too intense for them, too mature. That's fine. We can all say that. But at the end of the day, if they were really just against them buying things, because they're always their argument was free play Free associate of play which is of course is incredibly important to do was more like I'm gonna make up my whole world
当玩具公司、商业制作工作室和动画工作室之间那种有争议的关系破裂时。他对那些为实施这些法规而斗争的家长团体有意见。因为我的意思是，我们可以谈论内容，当然。我们想保护孩子免受那些实际上是暴力的，或者对他们来说太激烈、太成熟的东西的影响。这没问题。我们都可以这么说。但归根结底，如果他们真的只是反对他们买东西，因为他们的论点总是自由游戏，自由联想的游戏，这当然是非常重要的，更像是“我要编造我整个世界”，
I'm gonna make up doesn't matter if it's a stick or a rock or this or a bug I'm not going to have anything dictated to me. So a lot of critics would say yeah Well now you're saying that he man's good and Skeletor's bad It's binary and somebody told me that. And now I'm just playing the scripted show. My argument was like, no, I don't know how many kids really went in there and when he gives the exact script from the episode and I'm going to repeat it. Sure, there might have been tie ins. But at the end of the day, it was this doorway for an avatar play, an allegorical
“我要编造，不管是一根棍子、一块石头、这个还是一个虫子，我不会让任何东西支配我。”所以很多评论家会说，是的，好吧，现在你说希曼是好的，骷髅王是坏的，这是二元的，有人告诉过我。现在我只是在演那个剧本节目。我的论点是，不，我不知道有多少孩子真的会进去，当他给出剧集里的确切剧本时，我会重复它。当然，可能有关联。但归根结底，这是化身游戏、寓言式
play where they could conquer their own monsters, they could be the hero, they could deal with their anxieties, they could generate story. Then you take that all away and then what is the kid going to pick up? They're going to pick up a cell phone because that's the vacuum. My own little anecdotal moment is that my kids stumbled upon Godzilla as an IP. So I have to hunt high and low to find them the kid-ified pop vinyl toys that they can play with because most of the access is like, I can buy $200 Godzilla sculptures all day long, but I can't find the damn $30 toy for them because of the access isn't there at that level. So we live in a world where it's scary and it has big things and it has big things that kids are scared
游戏的一扇门，他们可以在那里征服自己的怪物，他们可以成为英雄，他们可以处理自己的焦虑，他们可以创造故事。然后你把这一切都拿走，那孩子会拿起什么？他们会拿起手机，因为那是真空。我自己的小轶事是，我的孩子们偶然发现了哥斯拉这个IP。所以我必须到处寻找那些适合儿童的Pop Vinyl玩具，让他们可以玩，因为大多数渠道都是，我可以整天买200美元的哥斯拉雕塑，但我找不到该死的30美元的玩具给他们，因为那个层面的渠道不存在。所以我们生活在一个可怕的世界里，它有巨大的东西，有让孩子们害怕的巨大东西，
about. And my kid had a lot of anxiety. And what he discovered Godzilla, all of a sudden his anxiety went out the window because you know what, he could conquer this monster. He could take a monster and put all of his focused energy and fear into something that he could control. And that's the beautiful thing that toys gave us. We began this mini series by talking about things that scared us in 1984.
关于这些。我的孩子有很多焦虑。当他发现哥斯拉时，突然间他的焦虑就消失了，因为你知道吗，他可以征服这个怪物。他可以拿一个怪物，把他所有的专注能量和恐惧投入到他能控制的东西中。这就是玩具给我们的美好之处。我们通过谈论1984年让我们害怕的事情开始了这一迷你系列。
I was a kid with a lot of anxiety. Maybe that's why I loved action figures so much. The toyetic craze of the 1980s was like a social experiment on the generation of kids. No wonder some of us grew up to become kiddults. I think our imaginations are richer because of it, but I also can't imagine it having been any other way. That is it for this week. Thank you for listening. Special thanks to Isaac Elliott Fisher, Andrew Ferrago, and Bob Budiansky. If you want to hear more about the creation of high-end collectible action figures, check
我是一个有很多焦虑的孩子。也许这就是我为什么那么喜欢人偶的原因。1980年代的玩具化热潮就像是对那一代孩子的一场社会实验。难怪我们中的一些人长大后成了“成人儿童”。我认为我们的想象力因此而变得更丰富，但我也无法想象它会以任何其他方式存在。本周节目就到这里。感谢收听。特别感谢艾萨克·埃利奥特·费舍尔、安德鲁·费拉戈和鲍勃·布迪安斯基。如果你想了解更多关于高端收藏级人偶的创作，请查看
out my 2014 episode, one of my first episodes, it's called Action Figure Land. My assistant producer is Stephanie Billman. If you like the show, please give us a shout out on social media, or leave a nice review where you get your podcasts. blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own discord server, which is about 2,500 people strong talking nice about architecture and power broker and all kinds of cool things. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 PI at 99i.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我2014年的一集，我最早的几集之一，叫《人偶乐园》。我的助理制片人是斯蒂芬妮·比尔曼。如果你喜欢这个节目，请在社交媒体上为我们点赞，或者在你获取播客的地方留下好评。我们在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大楼里。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们自己的Discord服务器，那里有大约2500人，讨论建筑、权力掮客和各种酷炫的事情。那里有一个链接，以及99 PI过去的所有剧集，网址是99i.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。